hallo mein name ist super und ich sehr
viele komische sachen im internet ich
war zum beispiel letztes mal irgendwie
oft haben da fragt mich nicht wieso ich
auf tumblr war ich hab selber keine
ahnung
jedenfalls habe ich dort ein paar
komische 3d animationen gesehen und dann
habe ich mal so ein bisschen
recherchiert und abgesehen ist die von
der website kurs wie die world sind und
da gibt es beispielsweise so war es oder
auch so war es oder auch sowas
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir
schauen uns davon auch mal was an und
reagiert darauf
[Musik]
okay was ist das für eine abgefuckte
ist ja so ein riesiger muffin oder war's
schlimmer für kommt raus und immer fürs
gehirn alles klar er scheiße aus dem
mund über den tisch und das war's das
sieht aus wie so ein spiel erst wenn ich
den typen jetzt irgendwie steuern könnte
jetzt weißt du mal gegenseitig
die kurzen grab aus
komm lass mich in ruhe wieder scheiße
[Musik]
war's jetzt liegt er im grab
was ist das für eine kranke scheiß auf
dieser website ein schweinegeld steig
auf verschwindet im himmelreich und das
war es das ist echt mega geil das ist so
ein palast da sitzt zum typ auf seinem
stuhl also dass ich echt übel gut
moduliert aus da sind leute die sich vor
ihm verneigen und ihn anbeten also das
ist glaube ich echt so das erste was ich
so ein bisschen sinn macht also erst
irgendwie so der gott oder so der herr
braucht hat er den gesichtern seinem
bauch
[Musik]
ende
diese modellierung heißt live world lift
ja ok
[Musik]
wieso ist die mutter so hässlich das
kind trainiert in ihrem bettchen mit
hanteln im alter von zirka 12 jahren
trainiert natürlich auch während des
unterrichts die dreht sich komplett mit
dem kopf um sind glücklich miteinander
laufen durch den rosenfeld heiraten
jetzt sogar und fahren jetzt zusammen
trecker und am haus das ist echt schön
wels ecken slater die beiden sind nackt
er wandert wieder zurück in die vagina
was habt ihr für eine kranke kreativität
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das was ihr wollt ihr mich verarschen
nackte männer in studen mitten im wasser
oder kommen wir nun hat dabei war zu
einigen meiner dieses video heißt the
world' deswegen würde ich echt ok in den
bauch von jemanden in der glaskugel von
jemandem da kommen köpfe hinter den
bäumen her
wahrscheinlich hat der arme hinter dem
rücken muss ich noch irgendwas erhitzen
übrigens sorry dass ich jetzt nicht so
viel schneide aber ich hab gedacht
solche videos gebe ich euch einfach am
besten wenn sie im ganzen sind und eben
eine komplette live reaktion darauf seht
also ich hoffe dass es okay für euch dk
was
was der typ sitzt auf einer wippe oder
wird dicker typ runter fallen gelassen
er wir durch eine röhre in das arschloch
von diesem menschen gefördert
seid ihr geisteskrank dieser film heißt
der hehler das heißt da ist ein art der
wohl jemanden heilt er hält seine hand
auf dem typen und die kamera zoomt
gerade an jemanden der ihnen dabei
beobachtet jetzt liegen die beiden
nebeneinander gemeinsam im bett und als
nächsten cut sehen wir dass sie
plötzlich auf einer wiese liegen jetzt
sitzen sie auf einer wiese und er sitzt
nackt auf dem boden
für mich ist das kriegt man was ist das
[Musik]
und die so müsst ihr immer alle nackt
seien ein kopf wird eine wippe runter
und auf einen tag und entnimmt der kopf
fliegt wieder durch eine höhere durch
ein schwein fängt ihn mit flügel
natürlich das schwein wie auch sonst
jetzt macht unser kopf eine riesen party
weiter geschleudert
durch die brust eines mannes und liegt
jetzt zwischen den beinen von einem
menschen der ihnen sich aufsetzt und
fernsehen kurz okay du bist dir wenn
mich meine oma fragt was ich beruflich
mache kann ich nicht sagen die beiden
leute schauen sich etwas anders dort
sitzt und zwar ein mensch mit einem baum
unter einem weinglas jetzt wird der
mensch frei gelassen er singt jetzt
fahren wir hier einen tunnel lang am
ende eine blaue tür und vor der tür
steht
das ist eine mikrowelle
ich glaube wenn man auf drogen jetzt
muss ich so was ankommt wird man echt
ein anderer mensch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das war's schon wieder was sowieso etwas
mitgeben fürs leben bis nicht guckt man
dass die ganze zeit an und denke mir
halt so jo ok das ist mega cool daran
kann ich jetzt wirklich was lernen die
leute sagen machen wir uns inspirieren
das ist etwas was die leute dazu
antreibt was zu machen man denkt einfach
darstellt gegen die botschaft dass wegen
der höheren metaebene hinter und dann
sieht man einfach so was
[Musik]
wohin mit meinem leben und wohin mit dem
leben von leuten die solos kreieren das
hier wird das letzte video was wir uns
heute von dieser website anschauen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was so heilige scheiße gut leute ich
mache urlaub das ist das auf welcher
hochzeit will ich hier gestoßen
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
wenn es alles getan hat las waren like
da werde ich das noch mal machen soll
alter leute ich bin krank gerade vom
kopf ich bin tot schreibt weil in die
kommentare
die world wenn ihr jetzt gerade noch
dran seid das zeigt mir einfach dass ihr
das video bis zum ende geschaut hat und
sonst würd ich sagen sehen wir uns
morgen in dem anderen video wie das war
echt krass hat mir gerade echt den rest
gegeben
ich war gerade die ganze zeit in der uni
und dann sehe ich nur so war es gerade
wo leute irgendwas modellieren hey ich
bin ich will fällig boris hat krank
gewesen hier findet hier ins weil ich
eigentlich blendet wenn ihr darauf
könnte meinen kanal abonnieren ist free
ist nice und ich habe neue abonnenten
also wenn mega cool und ihr findet hier
auch in mein letztes video eingeblendet
das war nämlich das größte pizzastück
der welt was ich mit max gebacken habe
war mega witzig geworden das video
schaut euch auf jeden fall mal an